Available at
retailers nationwide.
>> HERE WITH THE LATEST, OUR
VERY OWN RICK LEVENTHAL.
A BREAK?
>> A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
FOLLOWERS MAY BE SURPRISED WHAT
KANYE WEST, OBAMA, BILL GATES
AND OTHERS WERE POSTING ON THEIR
FEEDS.
JOE BIDEN’S ACCOUNT POSTED "I AM
GETTING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY,
ALL BITCOINS AND TO BE ADDRESSED
BELOW WILL BE DOUBLED.
"I’M ONLY DOING THIS FOR
30 MINUTES, ENJOY.
A BILLIONAIRE ELON MUSK HAD A
SIMILAR MESSAGE POSTED ON HIS
ACCOUNT, FEELING GRATEFUL.
CORPORATIONS INCLUDING APPLE
WERE VICTIMIZED, TOO.
PART OF A WIDESPREAD HACK ATTACK
ATTACK.
KANYE SAID HE COULD ONLY SPARE
10 MILLION BUCKS, AND AMAZON’S
JEFF PAZO SAID HE WOULD SHELL
OUT 50 MILLION.
SOME MESSAGES WERE QUICKLY
REPOSTED WHEN DELETED AND A LOT
OF FOLKS.
A SHORT TIME AGO, THE TWITTER
CEO JACK DORSEY TWEETED, OF
COURSE, TOUGH DAY FOR US.
YOU SEE THAT’S AN EARLIER
BATEMAN ABOUT THE SECURITY
INCIDENT.
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO HE TWEETED
TOUGH DAY FOR US TO TWITTER, WE
ALL FEEL TERRIBLE IT HAPPENED WE
ARE DIAGNOSING AND WILL SHARE
EVERYTHING WE CAN WHEN WE HAVE A
COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED.
I DON’T HAVE TO TELL YOU, IT IF
IT SOUNDS TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE,
IT PROBABLY IS.
>> Sean: ALL OF MY
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS BY MY
STAFF HERE, I DON’T EVEN KNOW
HOW TO GET INTO THEM.
I’D HAVE TO HIRE A HACKER TO GET
INTO IT.
I SAID THIS ABOUT -- ALL THAT
TALK.
I SAID, THEY GOT HACKED INTO THE
DOD AND NASA WHEN HE WAS 16.